[Música]
nós que vivemos hoje numa sociedade em
que vivemos com grandes um conjunto de
direitos e liberdades garantias e
elaboraram gerações das resoluções a
serem conquistadas ao ponto de agora os
nossos antepassados tem sentido a
necessidade de transpor em quer para a
nossa constituição quebrar o coração
universal dos direitos do homem
portanto são alguns conjuntos de
características que enquanto sobre a
sociedade nós queremos preservar e que o
desenvolvimento tecnológico de alguma
forma está agora a desafiar ou seja com
o desenvolvimento da tecnologia que
aconteceu nos últimos 30 anos
nós não conseguimos promover um conjunto
de situações mas há algo que nós
conseguimos prever que é o impacto que
esse desenvolvimento tem uma questão
essencial enquanto sociedade que é a
privacidade para falar sobre privacidade
então o melhor tempo para fazer é
começar por definir o que é privacidade
fui ver o que era o coração universal do
direito a mãe quer a própria
constituição portuguesa quer vários
artigos científicos e eu consegui
encontrar foi uma maldade nas missões um
cadu na ideia desta praga indiana que
são cegos estão aval para o front
ambienta para o funk pau montanha sua
própria por exemplo o infante
privacidade dos sexos todos nós
cada um tem a sua própria definição
privacidade e o envolvimento que nós
temos na sociedade o envolvimento que
nós temos na tecnologia condiciona essa
nossa transmissão
você então o que tentei fazer foi ver
aquilo que era comum é todas essas
transmissões de privacidade e que o que
é comum a todas essas definições de
privacidade o controlo é capacidade
quando nós tem de controlar a nossa
exposição à sociedade o que a tecnologia
tem feito de alguma forma e muito
silenciosa e muito devagar é desligado
este controlo que nós temos sobre a
nossa posição na sociedade
a questão é saber se devemos poder
voltar à praia que controla os realmente
privacidade
direito foi rodado em garantias que os
nossos antepassados valorizaram e com o
desenvolvimento da cidade de tecnologia
nós temos neste momento é valorizar mais
e devíamos a brincalhão quanto a esta
questão que devemos responder a um
conjunto de pessoas que eu conheço
muitas vezes não há privacidade não tem
nada a esconder nada a esconder sou um
cidadão exemplar um cidadão cumpridor e
portanto para mim a privacidade está
realmente ou right tem estado demasiado
valorizada pela sociedade e eu estou na
disposição de e de carga na privacidade
porque não tem nada a esconder e só quem
tem alguma coisa a esconder é que os
valores à privacidade
eu faço a pergunta aqui quantos de vocês
é que são adeptos desta a onda desta
nova tendência é que eles não têm nada a
esconder portanto só os criminosos e
tenta esconder a minha privacidade está
ou esteve quase que os desafiava o andré
não vou fazer porque porque já existe um
conjunto do idt as grandes empresas
mundiais têm de alguma forma e que são
lidas de empresas que condicionam a
opinião pública que tem feito passar
esta mensagem vocês 1002 afirmações
quando faz estas palestras mas para os
meus alunos e mais para o caos fundiário
de divulgação e faz realmente a pergunta
existe um conjunto de pessoas com hannah
a minha resposta é sempre vocês devem
ter uma vida muito a você mas muita
torcida mesmo sem dar um exemplo que é
um exemplo do total inscrito o líder
facebook tenha que a opinião sobre a
privacidade comprou sua casa e para
proteger a sua privacidade comprou mais
quatro casas á volta tem um caso
estranho em um caso contra intuitivo que
alguém que sendo três em sua privacidade
sinto ansiedade comprar quatro casas à
volta da sua para proteger a sua
privacidade e por que você nada é hoje
tema e porque é que a privacidade o
assunto é que não temos disse
nós nos últimos 30 anos fizemos incluir
a tecnologia como nunca as universidades
foram desafiados vocês foram desafiados
e vão continuar a ser desafiados a fazer
ruir a tecnologia e é nesse momento que
eu quero viver no mundo da tecnologia
evoluiu e podemos tirar partido dela
vejamos um exemplo só a forma com nossas
armas nomes late há 30 anos atrás novos
dados em cartões total procurado é isso
que nós armazenamento pois fomos
evoluindo esquetes 36 54 cv discos
externos pernas e pergunta agora é qual
é o próximo passo
conseguem antecipar nós temos o projeto
nossos dados nas nuvens na qual nós já
nem sabemos onde vamos em nossa cidade
próxima pergunta mas são as intensidades
porque está preocupado com isso
eu só tem meia dúzia de dados talvez não
vamos olhar por nós por um minuto na
internet o aumento por minuto
produzimos 2.4 milhões pesquisas no
google
enviamos 150 milhões correio por minuto
então se tiver um minuto que passa num
dia que passa o dia na internet
nós não dia na internet produzidos
globalmente 2.5 é debate eu sou
informático e quando vi essa informação
é que nós já vamos megan gíria thera
peta é até já tenha chegado drag queen
ex-bairro nenhum ex babá é é um guião
dioguardi é essa informação pode
inclusive porque é mais ou menos aquela
diferença para contador e
contextualizada não dizem o valor da
dívida portuguesa é o botão o surdo que
eu não consigo muitas coisas só quando
isso em centenas de milhões de euros que
é algo ainda passar um charter é que eu
consigo perceber o que o zé roberto é a
mesma coisa só quando contestou exames
lógica vai ficar que não estamos
habituados a gente e nós percebemos a
dimensão do problema que nós temos um
ponto realmente estamos a produzir muita
informação mas eu continuo aqui
estiveram
não tem nada a esconder e portanto não
tem nada a esconder não me importa que
outros tenham essa informação
cuidado com o que eu fazia sua opinião e
vamos tomar uma decisão informada
vamos ver o que é que as pessoas
conseguem fazer com este roubo de
informação
eu fui fazer uma consulta pública ou
seja fui ler o público faço isso todos
os dias de manhã chegou afobado primeira
coisa que faz jornais online deve somar
três pontos
ela é vamos ver o que acontece é a minha
expectativa é que o público fica saber
que o ideal seja que o número na
internet a minha máquina soubesse que eu
fui eu era aquela notícia em particular
do público
este gráfico está a mostra é quantidade
de instituições ficou a saber ou
empresas que ficaram a saber que eu fui
ver aquela notícia em particular do
público e circunferências que estão
contra são formais são empresas que nós
temos a certeza absoluta que fazem
profile do nosso o comportamento online
ou seja fazem o tracking estudo o nosso
comportamento online pergunta por que
isto é grave
agora começa a ficar abandonado porque
com base nas notícias como aol essas
empresas conseguem saber claramente a
minha tendência corrente conseguem saber
claramente os 1.100 3 do ponto vista
dobbs conseguem saber claramente seu
tempo frisou não porque se algo mais
grave aconteça crianças levou a ver
porque estou condicionado tem filhos
conseguem ter um conjunto grande de
informação sobre mim mas não é só no
público está generalizada
qualquer site nós vamos temos estas
empresas e maggi em tudo aquilo que
estamos a fazer todas as notícias não
estamos a ver depois temos aquela
empresa para a qual eu tive que é ainda
mais agressiva e consegue saber quais
são as pesquisas que nós fazemos o que é
que significa significa que se um filme
eu tiver uma doença qualquer quanto em e
o dia a transmissão de doenças x é que o
que eu faço no pediatra é não utilizar
nenhum tratamento o que é o xixi que por
muito que eu diga o que é o x eu quero
chegar a casa e ir à internet ver o que
significou seja o quanto a internet uma
forma muito calma ver o que significou x
o que estou a dizer estas empresas é que
minha casa nesse perfil exista alguém
que tenha alta tecnologia
agora começamos a ser reduzidos agora
começam a ser realmente é ainda mais
inclusivos porque tivemos a questões de
saúde
a samsung é mais íntimo nós temos é
enquanto ser humano contínuo e vamos ver
o que gugu não sabe sobre mim eu
mantenho esta praia é um time igual e
seu uso é enquanto o problema de uma
cidade que eu faço é ativar a
georeferenciação vou ao google maps e
vou procurar o corpo não quero ele mas
tipicamente um ano o gel que precisamos
cuidar dela
esse papel está vivíssimo todos os
planos que o google sabe que os títulos
não só isso todos os pontos do país onde
a google sabe que eu a ti vai à francesa
para mim estava partido precisava causa
disso eu queria fazer uma experiência
antes preparar esta apresentação foi um
dia de manhã liguei a já o francês a
minha casa
o google ficou exatamente saber e disse
eu fui ver pode que é que eu era a minha
casa disse que passados dez minutos eu
estava no colégio do meu filho ele se o
passado 15 minutos estavam focados e
passei o tempo nós quando andamos com
georreferenciação e adam estamos a dizer
todo o perfil que nós fazemos ao longo
do dia e são estes os 2.5 hexabytes
informação que nós temos é usado tanto
quando nos dizem que o serviço agora
esse serviço das redes sociais e
serviços não é bom nós estamos a pagar
opção brincar a dizer que não é bem um
literalmente mas nós estamos a pagar com
o nosso corpo
estamos a pagar com os nossos clientes
então vamos continuar e vamos agora
evoluir de empresas prestados
o presidente da urbana ou qual todos
nutrimos grandes simpatias soldado diz
em 2009 que os estados unidos não
estavam a fazer o próprio em cidadãs
estados unidos não estavam escutada
outros países em 2009 o que aconteceu
adwords na otan vai demonstrar que em
2007 o estado estava a fazer exatamente
aquilo que o obama disse que não estava
a fazer e mais grave que estavam a fazer
em outras nações a de uma serra antes de
ser eleita presidente do brasil já os
estados unidos tenham escutas
já os estados unidos não escutas no
ciberespaço
do comportamento para se verem quem era
aquela a candidata que tem um potencial
de ganhar as eleições no brasil
obviamente ficou irritada entre num
discurso com o qual o
sou completamente acordo nas nações
unidas em 2008 três anos o que ela vai
dizer foi o seguinte uma nação que na
qual não existe privacidade das pessoas
por cidadãos significa que não existe
liberdade de expressão por cidadãos e
muito bem
aquelas pessoas que dizem pra mim é
privacidade não é um problema porque eu
não tenho nada a esconder é equivalente
a dizerem eu como não tem nada a dizer
vou abdicar do livro da discussão é uma
certeza e à privacidade é uma certeza
porque uma vez perdida é com algumas
coisas na vida não se recupera
nós a brincar direito de usar a
expressão quando quiseram dizer alguma
coisa
não podemos fazer porque aplicamos e
será voltada então quais são as funções
não crê acabássemos dizer um conjunto
soluções a primeira função é ambulatório
é combinada do pai optou esse caminho
ser rua tutóia enforce de proteção à
privacidade dos seus cidadãos e o que
conseguiu com este conseguiu que o gol
fosse forçada a dar dos mecanismos a nós
de podermos controlar os nossos estádios
ou seja conseguir um conjunto de sites
da google e dizer ok todos os lados sabe
sobrinha já fez isso não esqueça e é
obrigado a pagar e já tem esse mecanismo
e permite-nos outras coisas permite
controlar os dados pesquisas e consigo
chutar a gol e dizer ok os meus dados
pesquisa no imel ano negou
não quero que faça estará quem diz não
quero usar maçãs tanta comunidade no
país a conquista do vozão vai
desenvolver nos o controlo sobre os
nossos dados muito podemos fazer algo
mais podemos desenvolver tal como
desenvolvemos a tecnologia para chegar a
este ponto podemos desenvolver
tecnologias sejam potenciadores da
privacidade
dois exemplos muito caros este é um
exemplo do hospital que nos pediu que
queria fazer um estudo sobre a
prescrição dos médicos não quis saber se
a américa x ou y cristal fazer um estudo
sobre aquela opção e
comportamental tirou todos os
identificadores dos médicos todos eles
não só tentam agora podemos trabalhar e
nós temos não é o que nós fizemos
nós fomos ao facebook criamos um perfil
de um conjunto de jovens rapazes e
raparigas 9 e bem visto
temos amizade aos méritos naquela
hospital e os médicos receitaram a dado
momento diziam que eu estou de férias e
era criança que havia alguns perfis
prescrição que é uma zero
portanto por muita organização que
houvesse nós conseguimos que identificar
a causa traçados
conseguimos saber que o perfil
prescrição era de que o médico porque
era um mágico feito mas eu prometo vos
função que nós fizemos criamos algo mal
estar gerado alguma entropia fizemos um
chip nas latas e conseguimos de alguma
forma proteger a privacidade dos
profissionais
outro exemplo é este é um exemplo
simples é em 2006 havia uma solução é
nova em portugal sobre a proteção para
cidades net que farão os dados médicos
dizem respeito não só a mim como aos
meus descendentes e os meus descendentes
algo realmente muito intrusivo na
privacidade e se uma resolução
específica o hospital são joão quis
fazer o informe mantendo o sangue e ter
primeiro um grupo de médicos ao qual têm
acesso àquela de comoção
mas nos dados o outro é realmente
crítico e um médio que quer tratar um
doente tenha acesso à informação na que
o momento não pode estar ligado à
informática e dizer olha o irregular
porque eu tenho que estar aqui
o que nós fizemos podemos um papa eo
médio por muito não tenha na política ea
direita será causados mas vamos permitir
que isso aconteça mas é o tempo nos
dizer o porquê é que vai fazer e fica
logo avisada nós notificamos o
responsável clínico o diretor do
hospital mais deputados médicos não
continuam sem violência
então enquanto informático resta nos dar
o meu último conselho e ao conseg em
formato típico vamos fazer reboots a
nossa máquina vamos fazer rir button
nosso comportamento online e vamos
começar a ganhar controlo sobre o nosso
retorno
[Aplausos]